night also big breaking news out of
virginia a monmouth poll now showing the
gubernatorial race between glenn
youngkin and terry mcauliffe is now dead
even 46-46
terry he's feeling the pressure storming
out of an interview with a local
reporter 10 minutes earlier saying you
need to ask better questions take a look
healthcare covet education job creation
all right we're over that's it that's it
i gave you extra time come on man you
should ask better questions early on
you still ask questions your viewers
care about
what we did
you should have asked better questions
oh okay now democrats they're pulling
out all those stops they're trying to
save mcauliffe including bringing in
kamala harris not sure how much good
that does who is under fire herself for
a video urging churchgoers to get out
and vote which uh it appears may have
actually violated irs rules of course if
you're a democrat you get a pass if
you're a republican you get 10 years in
jail and as glenn young can put it terry
mcauliffe is clearly losing it totally
unraveling and don't forget mcauliffe
has made it very clear he does not want
parents involved in their kids education
and wants to set the stage for more
far-left indoctrination don't take my
word for it listen to terry himself
i don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach let's you
know i get really tired of everybody
running down teachers
dead even race and it's all coming down
to turnout and who gets their voters to
the polls november the second can deep
blue virginia deep blue state really
turn red here to make that case he's now
tied tonight republican virginia
gubernatorial candidate glenn younkin is
with us uh obviously this is a real race
now obviously he's nervous uh you have
distinguished yourself you believe
teachers actually parents should have
input in their kids school i would tend
to agree with you you said you'd
eliminate crt
on day one what are the major
differences in your campaign
well sean thank you for having me
tonight and the reason why terry
mcauliffe doesn't want to talk to that
reporter anymore is because the reporter
was asking him questions about schools
and crime
and terry doesn't think that voters want
to want to hear about schools and crime
well last night we had an event in
fairfax county we had a thousand people
show up
a thousand people know the difference
between what i'm going to do for
virginians is get our schools
reestablished with standards of
excellence where parents have a
fundamental right to be engaged in their
children's education terry mcauliffe
wants government between parents and
their children i'm going to cut taxes
and terry mcauliffe wants to raise taxes
i'm standing strong for law enforcement
terry mcauliffe is running around with
politicians who want to defund police
and close prisons and oh by the way i'm
going to get our job machine cranked
back up and when terry mcauliffe was
governor 40 percent of his economic
projects failed to create a single job
on the ballot right now in november is
the future of virginia and sean it's the
future of america because virginia gets
to stand up and vote over the course of
the next 13 days and make a statement
for a state that yeah a state that's
been blue that's getting ready to elect
a republican governor and charge forward
with a new new day in virginia the the
county of loudoun loudoun county has
become a central point in this campaign
serious allegation of a rape in a
bathroom of a young woman confirmed
investigation again nothing's proven yet
but a confirmed investigation by law
enforcement but then the student was
apparently transferred to another school
now there's another allegation of
another assault
and my question is pending the results
of that investigation why was that
student
still allowed in any school and how did
the the board of super the
superintendent say that he knew nothing
about it when the police knew all about
it
this is something that i called for last
night an investigation of the loudoun
county school board the fbi should leave
virginia's parents alone
and focus on what's happening in loudoun
county schools
i mean we absolutely had a perpetrator
and offender who was being
investigated and prosecuted for sexual
assault and and they tried to hide him
in another school
and he did it again
i mean the school board and oh by the
way the school administrators are guilty
of gross negligence and they should be
held accountable people should be fired
people should lose their jobs or resign
and that's why i called for a full
investigation and oh by the way if if
virginia's current attorney general mark
herring who's out campaigning a divisive
campaign isn't willing to do it just
wait until january 15th when we show up
and jason miara's who will be our next
attorney general and i and win some
sears we're going to have a full
investigation we're going to find out
what happened virginia parents deserve
this our schools aren't safe our schools
are teaching our kids what to think as
opposed to how to think we're going to
go to work on day one and re-establish
excellence in schools but on top of that
safety
uh we appreciate you being with us glenn
younkin
if you win this race
it will be a political earthquake that
will be heard all around the country and
you're dead even we wish you luck we're
going to follow this very closely thanks
for being with us